I
grew up in Yatsushiro in the Far East,
poor, but everyone was warm and white.
Haruhime was born in a noble family and lived almost without going
out.It seems that he heard rumors about Yashiro.
[Music]
Stew
I can't eat this much please  Please share it with the four
white gods.
And that person who always looks lonely couldn't see the bamboo ball
.
I tried to get rid of the sabisa from that person who helped me
, so I got high status from Takemikazuchi-sama, and I sneaked in easily with Yachigusa Do Oozumi,
and exchanged lookouts every day
to Haruhime's back mountain.  I took him out
one day, but he found out about it, but after that, he repeated the offense and defense with three bowls of water, and he repeated
over and over again
.
After that, we left the Far East and
went to Rio
to earn money and send it to
Yashiro.
If Haruhime was deceived by
someone heartless and sold to a human trafficker,
I want to help him if he's suffering now